This video might save you 20 years of
your life or maybe just move your life
20 years forward. My name is Alex
Ramoszi. I run acquisition.com. It's a
portfolio of companies that last year
did over $250 million in aggreate
revenue. And so here's the thing. You
don't need to own a company for this to
work. You just have to have more dollars
than you have time and want to make a
trade. Some of the recommendations will
add up $20,000 a year. But you can get
started as long as you make over 15
bucks an hour. And I'm going to show you
seven investments and the exact order to
do them that will save you an entire
week every single month. and that's a
quarter of your life. The first thing is
getting your meals taken care of. And so
whether you use Uber Eats or you use
pre-made meals, it's about 16 bucks an
hour in terms of cost to get this done
for you. And so if as long as you make
more than $16 an hour, you still
arbitrage on your time. And many people
who are especially trying to reinvest in
their time, even if you didn't, as long
as you use that extra time to increase
your skill set, it's absolutely worth
it. So these are all the things just
outsourcing your meal prepping to gets
you back. So number one is groceries. So
all the time you spend driving to the
store, coming back from the store,
unloading the groceries into your
pantry, all of that time. The next is
meal planning, cuz believe it or not,
you're think, well, what am I going to
have for dinner tonight? And that takes
mental bandwidth. On top of that, you
have, okay, well, if I know what I'm
going to have, I still have to cook it,
right? And then after you do the
cooking, what do you do? You got to do
the cleaning, right? And then on top of
that, you then have to still prep all
the food, as in like I have to store it
and I have to put it away in the fridge
and I have to portion it out if you're
going to do something like that. And
whether you do it at the time you cook
it or when you eat it, you're still
portioning it for yourself. And it still
takes time and it still takes bandwidth.
And the average American spends 13.5
hours per week. Huge per week, right?
That's two full work days. Think about
that, right? 13 and 12 hours a week just
doing this stuff. that's not really
value additive. And so right now you can
get two meals a day, which is what I
recommend. Have a shake in the morning,
do a lunch and a dinner. Makes it very
easy. Times 30 days per month. And
that's about $750 per month. That sounds
like a big ticket, but remember, you're
not buying groceries anymore. You're not
buying anything else because all of that
food is getting delivered. And just
don't eat anything besides that. It
also, as a side note, is a great way to
get in shape if you're a little bit
overweight. Now, I will give you an
alternative if you're somebody who likes
to have a little bit more variety.
There's a lot of, you know, I would say
self- finance, whatever, you know, type
people, they'll say never eat out and
all that kind of stuff. I would say just
my my life exists as an exact opposite.
I eat out all the time. And I just see
this is as more flexible meal prepping
that another business does more
efficiently than me. And so for a period
of multiple years, I eat Chipotle twice
a day. And it came out, it was like 500
plus transactions at Chipotle, uh, that
my accountant told me. And he was like,
I can't believe you're spending so much
money. I was like, but think of how much
time I'm saving. And also, I was like,
"Look at my grocery bills. They're
non-existent." Because I only thing I
was buying was Red Bull and Coke Zero,
right? So, if you want to Uber Eats or
you want to order and have somebody
deliver to you, I think it's totally
fine. It does cost a little bit more,
but net net, it's up to you. So, boom.
13 and 1/2 hours saved. But we're not
done yet. So, this is laundry. And guess
what? The average American spends, do
you think it's 1 hour, 2 hours, 4 hours
a week? That's a half a workday. four
hours per week doing clothes cleaning
related activities. So that means 30
minutes a week sorting your actual stuff
and folding it. Putting it away is like
an hour plus per week. Washing and
drying cycles typically you have to be
close to it. That's 2 hours a week. And
so in total it's 4 hours per week which
is 16 hours per month. All right. So
again, boom, we just found two work days
right there per month. And so the
question is, okay, well if you can get
two full work days back, you should
totally do that. Well, how much does it
cost? Right. Well, you can do drop off
service. Drop off service is usually 1
and a half to two bucks a pound, right?
At least in the US today. All right. And
so, most people average 30 to 40 lbs a
month. Unless you're crazy and you're
big fashion icon. I don't know. I mean,
I'm obviously a fashion icon, so I know
all about this, but the monthly cost is
somewhere in the neighborhood of $60 to
$80. Now, you might be wondering like,
why didn't I start with this one rather
than the groceries? The thing, the
reason I like the groceries one is I
think it's for many people, they want to
get in shape better. This can check
multiple boxes. Like you can have better
energy. You can clear up your skin if
you eat too much oily You can lose
weight and save time. It just like it
checks so many boxes up front. It's one
of the first things I recommend. This
one is small and obvious. Like I have
never I've not met many founders who are
like, you know what I really look
forward to? Laundry, right? Like just
I've never heard it. Some people love
cooking. Different thing. But as far as
your your your your daily drivers in
terms of activities, not worth it. So,
there's a picture of Leila and I
actually sitting outside of laundromats
working on our laptops. We did this
because we were actually moving around
the country so often that it was very
difficult for us to find like a specific
laundroer, I guess you could call it. It
was actually just faster. So, as a side
note, I actually think that laundromats
do make sense, especially if you waste a
whole day going from laundry to cleaning
to dry all day long while you're
watching the football game or whatever
it is. Way better to just go there, get
it all done, and then be out. And I'll
give you the world's smallest tip.
Smallest tip. If you do choose to wear
the same thing every day, it makes it so
easy to get up and go every morning.
Like, cuz I have one shelf that just has
wife beers and then I have a shelf below
it that has black shorts and I grab one
from here and one from here and I can do
it in the dark. So, I zero thinking and
I'm out the door in like 5 seconds. All
right, so so far we save 13 and 1 half
hours a week with groceries and we save
four hours a week with laundry. So,
what's next? Jesus. Next up is house
cleaning. So someone to clean your house
or apartment. Just think bathrooms,
kitchen, floors, dusting, just kind of
the whole place. So this is how much it
actually saves for you. So on average,
the average American spends 3 to 4 hours
doing a weekly deep clean and about 30
minutes per day, which is another 3ish
hours per week tidying up their home or
their desk or their room or their
workspace, whatever. And so in total,
we're looking at another six to seven
hours per week, which gives us 26 hours
per month. All right. I also, weirdly,
have yet to meet an entrepreneur who's
like, you know what, I really love just
deep cleaning, you know, just putting
the putting the gloves on and getting in
the shower grate and like picking up the
oven thing or the the stove top and
getting in there. I mean, some people
are crazy, don't get me wrong, and if
you love cleaning, then by all means,
you can skip this one, but most people
don't. And so if you can get yourself
another, remember this is 26 hours per
month, three more work days per month
that we're adding back to your life. And
the total cost is as long as you make
more than 20 bucks an hour, it makes
sense. And so our monthly cost here all
in. So we had our 60 to 80 here. Here
we've got our 200 to 300 per month. And
then here we've got our 750 per month.
All right. So you can see as we're
adding this up, we're making progress.
We're chipping away. We're buying time
back. My team just asked me when did I
start investing in this? The real real
answer is I just didn't clean. And the
way that I didn't clean is that I just
wouldn't touch anything in my apartment
because I didn't want anything to get
dirty so I wouldn't have to clean. So,
so far we've saved 13 hours a week, 4
hours a week, and 6 hours a week in
total. So, we're looking at 23ish hours
per week. And it cost us 750 60 plus
200. All right. So, all in, we're
looking at a,000 bucks a monthish right
now for an extra 23 hours per week.
We're talking multiple work days per
week already. You seeing how this stuff
adds up? So, let's do the next one.
Blackout curtains and earplugs. All
right. Now, I'm telling you, in terms of
ROI, like you spend a third of your life
sleeping and the idea that so few people
have optimized what they spend a third
of their life in, like you spend so much
on your car, you spend so much on your
house, but a third of your life, right,
is spent in a bed, it's it is the
cheapest environment to optimize. I live
in Vegas and so there's lots of noise
and so for me I have earplugs that I put
in and if you ever try doing these the
first like week or so your ears ears
will hurt a little bit then you will
100% adjust and you don't feel it at all
and now I only sleep with earplugs like
I can't hear anything and just the the
ocean sound you know when you like put
it in it's like that sound is now like I
I just like I'm ready to I'm ready to
pass out. But on top of that, you want
it to be dark enough that when you open
your eyes, you can't notice that your
eyes are open. So you open and it's just
as black as when you're closed. That's
when you've dark darkened it enough. You
can also get electrical tape because
sometimes there's tiny little lights
that you have in your room, just put
electrical tape on them. And electrical
tape doesn't usually rip off paint or
anything like that. And so those three
things like so worth it. Now, if you
want to spend a little bit more money, I
think it's like about two grand one
time, you can get one of those cooling
mattresses. I strongly recommend it,
especially if you live with somebody,
well, you sleep with somebody rather. I
strongly recommend getting one of those
sleep mattresses that cools you down. It
also will dramatically reduce your
heating and cooling bill because so we
have to we cool our entire house just so
that when we're underneath of the the
blanket, it's a certain temperature, but
you can just cool that tiny area and
it'll save you a ton of money. So, I
think net net it'll actually save you
money on your bill, especially if you're
at work all day or anything like that.
If you like sleep masks, you can use
those. I would recommend the ones that
have the the big cups. I actually do
both. So, I have blackout curtains and
that like I don't want to see or hear
anything. You probably already know
this, but you probably don't do it,
which is don't watch TV on your phone,
whatever, before you go to bed. And as
soon as you get one of these mattresses
that tracks your sleep, what you'll
notice is that you your REM sleep gets
pushed back. And so, one of the things
is like if you ever feel like, man, I
feel like I've got no juice in the
middle of my brain. You know, you get
that tired feeling. So, the no juice
thing is not because you have no juice
left. It's actually because you
accumulated waste in your brain. And so
you need your to give your brain time to
basically clear the waste out so that it
can function properly again. And so
that's functionally all we're trying to
do here. So how many hours this gets you
back? I think it's more that it
increases the productivity per hour. If
we can get another 2 hours of
productivity out per day without
actually creating more time, to me, it's
still a net benefit. And again, this is
one of the cheapest ones you can do cuz
they're onetime expenses that have
permanent improvements. And I'm so
hardcore about this. Like I will buy it
for a founder who doesn't have it. And I
was like, "Stop what you're doing right
now. Whatever." Like, immediately put
whatever money you're making out towards
doing this. Like, it's a it's a
non-starter. It makes no sense for to
not get better rest. Like, you live
longer. You're in a better mood. You
make higher quality decisions. You have
more energy. Like, you recover better if
you train in your workout. Like, there's
zero sense to not doing this. All right.
Next up,
landscaping. So, I actually don't assume
that you were truly landscaping. You
probably use a lawn mower, but that
would have been more difficult for me to
catch out of thin air. And so we're
going with this thing. As we're moving
through this, we're going up in how much
it costs, right? One of the things to
remember is like you only get these
savings once. Like I can't go back and
get this ROI again. Like if right now I
could go get myself another 100 hours a
month for 1,500 bucks a month. My god, I
go to the Time Store and just buy it
over and over and over again. I would
jam on the purchase button. You can only
do it once, which is why I think it's
one of the highest ROI purchases you can
ever make. How much does this normally
cost people? Well, it normally saves you
1 to 2 hours per week just for mowing.
Now, obviously that's seasonal depending
on where you live. The next you've got
weeds and trimming, which is another 2
hours. Now, this is per month. All
right, so this is a little bit less, but
again, like as we get further up here,
you're going to get less time for more
for more money, but that's just the
trades you make. You've got gutter
stuff, gutter cleaning, all right, which
you should do cuz otherwise your house
will get all messed up if you are into
that kind of thing. That's about 4 hours
twice a year. And so on average, it's
about eight hours per month. And so all
in you're looking at about $300 per
month to get that time back. Now again,
you'll notice that the dollars per hour
continues to go down. But like, welcome
to becoming more successful. Like you
have to spend more. And then once you've
done all these ones, it only gets more
expensive from there. But these are the
easiest ones that I get almost all my
initial founders to commit to. Now,
let's look at the next one. Wo, it's a
car. Very small car. And hopefully
you're driving a car bigger than this
one. Now, before I get into this, let's
look at what you've saved so far. 13 and
a half hours per week for $750 a month.
You've got four hours that you're saving
with laundry for about 60 bucks a month.
You got 6 hours that you're saving with
cleaning and cleaners for your house.
Then you've got sleep, which is just
going to get you more hours for all this
stuff for about 200 bucks a month if you
financed out one of these fancy
mattresses. And at least the the
earplugs and the the blackouts are super
cheap. Then you've got 2 hours a week
that you're saving for landscaping and
mowing and all that kind of jazz. And so
if we're adding this as we go, which I
hope you are, it's like we're looking at
800ish, 1,000ish 1,200ish, 1,500ish per
month. Now, hey, I'm not saying this is
cheap stuff, but what is it getting you?
You're getting in total so far 10 hours,
23 1/2 hours plus more for that time.
Now we're at 25 1/2 hours per week.
Three full work days per week back,
which most people are just wasting their
weekends on this stuff. What am I doing
with this car? All right. So, if now if
you make over $50 an hour, you should
consider this. So, what is this? So,
this is you can either get a driver if
you want to be a super baller, right? Or
you can just use the virtual driving
economy that exists, which is Uber and
soon to be Tesla taxis or whatever it
is, and the driverless fleets that are
going to be there. Cuz I'll bet you
that's also going to dramatically
decrease the cost of having someone
drive you to and from places. It's going
to approximate the cost of energy. It's
like energy plus depreciation on the
car. like that's going to really be the
equation for transport which is amazing
for all humans because when you look at
how economies work the base the base
level of everything is energy and then
from energy above that you have
transportation and so it's a very
foundational level of like how efficient
an economy is and so for you if you
could take the 30 minutes a day or 45
minutes a day that you spend commuting
which by the way the average if you're
curious about it is 1 to 2 hours let's
just call this 1.5 hours per day that
people spend and that also Alo doesn't
include the hassle of parking and you
know walking from wherever they are at
to their actual final destination. And
so believe it or not this is a monster
one. So this is about 30 hours per month
conservatively that people spend up to
50 depending on where you live. And so
the question is okay that's a lot of
hours and we said 50 bucks an hour to
start this cuz you got to be willing to
spend a little bit more to get this. So
in general this is going to probably run
you somewhere in the neighborhood of
like 600 to a,000 per month. And you're
like why is the range so big? Well, it
depends how far you drive and how much
you drive, right? But it's a pretty
penny. At the same time though, there's
also a lot of hours back. But you might
be thinking, well, how do I how do I
make those hours productive? That's a
key point, right? So, a lot of the
tweets that you see for my account and
whatnot, I actually tweet while I'm I'm
being driven, right? And so, that way
I'm either checking Slack messages that
I have so I can update, you know,
threads and ASA boards and whatnot. I'm
kidding. I'm not on a sauna, but like
whatever. I'm sure people could do that,
but for me, it's it's tweeting and
checking Slack to make sure that I can
move the ball forward on the projects
that I'm involved in. All right, let's
zoom zoom to the next one. And I'll just
draw it for you because this is what
we're looking at, which is getting a
plane. There you go. You don't have to
buy a jet. But what you don't know is
that you can also just get semi-private
flying. So, I found out about this way
too late in my life, but you can
basically there's plenty of places like
JSX. I think JetBlue has some of this
stuff where you can get on a plane with
like 20 people. And by doing that, you
get avoid all of the TSA, all the
security. You literally just roll up to
the plane, walk in, walk out. And as
somebody who flies a lot of private, I'm
telling you, it's so close to what you
get in private for such a fraction of
the of the price, it's a great deal. And
so probably somewhere in the
neighborhood of like triple the cost of
travel, but if you compare that to what
private costs, it's way less. So, like
if for example, if I want to go from
here to LA, so I'm in Vegas and that's a
30 or 45 minute flight, it's still going
to probably run me 15 grand, maybe 20
for that for that flight. There's
obviously roundtrip, things like that,
but let's just use 20 as a as a
placeholder. For the same JSX flight,
it's probably 300 bucks. Now, you could
get a Spirit or something like that for
probably like 50 or 60 if you if you
time it right, maybe 99. So, it's going
to be about triple the cost of one of
the kind of commercial airlines, but the
amount of time you save instead of
honestly instead of it being a travel
day, you just work and then you just
drive to the place, you get on the
plane, add 30 minutes, and then you're
wherever you're at. And so, if you have
to travel for work, I just like I can't
recommend it enough. So, on average, if
you fly 50 to 100 hours per year, it's
going to be somewhere around 1 hour per
week. And how much does this cost? Well,
this is going to cost you significantly
more, right? But the thing is is that
that one if you travel, if you include
all the other cost associated with it in
terms of time, sometimes this can be 10
hours, right, per week if you travel,
you know, a lot. And so this one's super
variable, but usually it's going to cost
you somewhere in the neighborhood of
a,000 bucks a month on top of what you
would normally spend. If we're adding
all this up and we do this weekly, you
got 13 and 1/2, you got 17 and 1/2,
you've got 23 and 1/2, you've got more
optimization. You got 25 and a half,
you've got 26, 27, and then you've got 8
on top of that, 35, and then 10 here,
you're 45. You basically buy yourself an
entire week back. Now, if you're like,
wait, hold on. If I did that, I'd have a
whole another work week. Well, the
answer is kind of yes. And I'll explain
what I mean. A lot of people want to
work all day and they work their
available hours per day, but many of
their hours are taken up by what I call
humaning, right? Which is doing the
stuff that you have to do. Like I got to
feed this thing and then I got to clean
this thing, this bodysuit that I wear,
right? I got to take it from place to
place, right? It's such a pain. So if we
add all this up, 750, 60, 200, 200, 300,
600, 1,000, we're looking at 3,100ish.
So three grand a month to get all these
benefits. Now, if you're not traveling
as much, boom, you're at like 2,000ish
per month. Now, some of you might be
like, "Well, in my market, you'd be
crazy to get that." It's like, great.
Well, you probably also earn more cuz
you're also in that market. So, chill
out. All right. The point here is the
concept more than the actual dollars and
cents. And the time is real, right? Now,
some of you like, I don't spend that
much time cleaning. Amazing. I love that
for you. And for everybody else, find
use. All right. But the big picture is
if we think about focus as the
hypothetical extreme which is doing
nothing except for the task that we set
out to do then anything that is not that
task distracts us from the ultimate goal
that we have. And so this may seem crazy
to outsource humaning but unless you get
significant value or purpose or meaning
from doing some of these more mundane
activities then I would strongly
recommend getting yourself an entire
week per week back. And so if you can do
that, like I I said at the very
beginning of this video, you can get 10
years back, but you could probably get a
lot more than that in terms of
productive hours, right? Because you're
sleeping eight, so you really only have
16, right? So if all of a sudden you can
get an extra four, five, six per day
back because you're not doing all this
other stuff. All of a sudden people are
like, "How does he get so much done?"
It's like, "Well, I literally have two
weeks for every week." And this is
accessible for anybody who has a
business over a certain level. And you
don't have to do it all at once. You
could start if we had to make an order
here of where I would order these. I did
it in the order that I would recommend
doing it. So, I would do this first. Get
your meals and stuff taken care of.
Second, get your laundry and stuff taken
care of. Then, you've got your cleaning
for the house. Get that taken care of.
Next, this one. I would say make this
zero. You should for sure do this, but I
didn't want to start with sleep because
it wasn't an hourish thing, but I think
super important. Okay. After that,
you've got your your lawn care and all
that other jazz. All in, we have seven
if we include our zero. And so you can
do them in this order and they cost this
much and it's one of the highest returns
you can get on your time, more than the
S&P 500. Go spend this money so you can
increase your active income rather than
obsessing over passive and you will
think yourself forward in a few years.